As we wrap up this course, I'd like to point out that animation production with a game engine is a challenging but rewarding process.
It allows for instantaneous feedback at a level of visual quality that most DCCs can't match.
Plus, Sequencer's feature set is designed to address many production requirements.
However, if you need more help, there are many things you can do to make your experience in engine a more productive one.
The first thing you can do is to concentrate on project and level organization.
Unreal, as a game engine, is designed to achieve real-time results within the limits of existing GPU hardware.
Unlike traditional production that usually has more computational resources,
you should go into your projects prepared and with a plan to optimize your environments and animation performances
for greater efficiency based off of your GPU's capabilities.
By learning how to use a game engine, you'll ultimately become a better production artist.
Most linear content projects rely on large environments and multiple scene setups for shot-based workflows.
One of the ways that Epic addresses this issue is by using levels and sub-levels,
whereas game productions will most likely use world partition for open-world gameplay.
The level editor is critical for organizing your environment by creating specific sub-levels.
The primary level or map that pairs with your master level sequence will contain what is known as the persistent level.
By default, everything resides here, including anything that is newly added to the level,
but once artists start creating additional sub-levels, they're more free to assign different purposes for them.
By double-clicking on any one of these additional sub-levels, newly added actors can be placed within them.
Depending upon your particular project, levels and sub-levels can be used for environmental organization,
sequence lighting setups, effects, special camera moves, or whatever you need.
Then within Sequencer, these levels can be turned on or off by using visibility tracks.
The result allows the artist to selectively visualize the portions of the environment on a scene-to-scene basis.
Another technique to keep yourself and your project running smoothly is to create a logically organized nested folder structure
in your content browser and your project outliner as much as possible.
While some studios do have their own organizational techniques, many do not.
Lack of a common folder structure can make it difficult to hand off projects to other members of your team.
A considerable amount of time is wasted by artists trying to dissect other people's work.
Make it easier on them and adopt this technique especially if you're working within a group.
Of all the organizational tools in Sequencer, sub-scene tracks unquestionably remain one of the most powerful tools you can use.
This particular type of track is designed to take nested level sequences and use them as a potential layering source inside your parent level sequence.
Depending upon your needs, sub-scene tracks can be used to separate out specific creative tasks like animation, effects, camera, lighting, and sound.
By individualizing your creative requirements into separate tracks, you permit artists to work more collaboratively with one another.
Since each sub-scene track is a separate level sequence, departments or individual artists can check out the sub-scene via source control
while still allowing other artists to work within the parent level sequence.
Sub-scene tracks can be edited, retimed, shuffled, or turned on and off if needed.
When combined with a level editor, projects can be highly organized and yet remain quite flexible for large or small teams working together.
Project organization remains one of the most important aspects of any production.
In order to improve your chances of success, Epic has collected a number of relevant production tips and resources that can help you along the way.
We'll take a look at that in our next section.